الملف النووي والتفاوض بين ايران والقوى
الغربيه يعود الى مربع الخلاف الولايات
المتحده واطراف الاتفاق النووي بريطانيا
وفرنسا والمانيا قدمت للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه مشروع قرار يدين عدم تعاون
ايران مع الهيئه الامميه بشان وجود مواد
نوويه في مواقع غير مصرح عنها مشروع
القرار قدم عشيه عقاد الاجتماع الفصلي
لمجلس محافظي وكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
حول اثار اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في
مكان لا يجب ان تكون فيه
مجتمع دولي لدينا الكثير من الاسئله
المفتوحه التي تبحث عن اجوبه
قالت ان سلوك طهران في التعامل مع
الاحتجاجات في البلاد يعد سببا اضافيا
لتجديد ضغوط حول ملف ايران النوويه
او امتلاك اسلحه النوويه
اغلاق المتاجر في بازار طهران الكبير
وكذلك في مدن ايرانيه اخرى بمناسبه تنظيم
عشرات الايرانيين مظاهرات في مدن مختلفه
تزامنا مع ذكر مرور ثلاث سنوات على حمله
قمع داميه لاحتجاجات نظمت اثر رفع اسعار
الوقود